the Eagles victory touched off a wild
celebration in Philadelphia at one point
the awning in front of the Ritz Carlton
Hotel collapsed under the weight of more
than a half dozen fans DeMarco Morgan is
outside the hotel DeMarco good morning
good morning Nora it was wild indeed
Eagles fans swarmed to downtown Philly
and parts of Broad Street to celebrate
the Eagles Victor in this awning right
here at the ritz-carlton it was pulled
down during that celebration but the
destruction doesn't stop there as the
Eagles claimed their first ever Super
Bowl title soda fans thousands taken to
the streets of downtown Philadelphia the
celebration quickly got rowdy fans
pulled down traffic lights started fires
and tipped over cars some climbed to the
awning of the ritz-carlton jumping one
by one into the crowd
eventually it gave way had the group
tumbled to the ground it's unclear if
anyone was injured police were left
powerless as this fan hopped on top of a
police van riding it through the massive
crowd police on bikes and in riot gear
tried in vain to clear the crowd earlier
in the day authorities rubbed hydraulic
fluid on light poles to try and prevent
climate and the efforts to keep fans of
climbing poles it didn't work but the
Eagles are happy
[Applause]
fans were not just united in their love
for their team but also in their dislike
to any love for Tom Brady
now Wednesday when the Eagles are
expected to parade down Broad Street it
will be the first championship parade in
the city and nearly a decade sorry Nora
it looks like everybody had a good time
there last night on congratulations them
tomato thank you so much